Now that muddy
mess couldn't stop Diplo
from making it to his next concert.
The DJ posted to his Instagram
saying that he walked
six miles
through the mud out of the desert
before hitchhiking his way
out of the festival
to make sure to make sure that he made it
to Washington, D.C.
on time
And he was joined by Chris
Rock in the back of a truck
with a group of fans
Diplo made it to the airport, walking
barefoot on the tarmac
and posted to his Instagram, quote,
No one believed we would get to the days,
would get to D.C. for the show tonight.
But God did so.
Joining us now is three time
Grammy Award winner Diplo.
Welcome to the program.
Hi. How are you guys doing?
Good.
So were you
barefoot and walking,
duct tape and bags walking?
What were we dealing with here in
terms of a plan to get out?
I try
to duck tape and
walking back
some pretty good boots that zippers
and sort of tires.
And they worked pretty well.
They they were caked with mud,
so they got pretty heavy.
There were like £3 each at one point.
So I had some pretty strong leg muscles
after that walk.
But when you started to walk in the mud,
you kind of realize
you have to stay low to the ground.
And it's very slippery.
And if you don't walk on
where it was chewed up from tire marks,
it's pretty easy to move out of there.
What was it like watching you?
What was it like watching other people?
I mean, was there a lot of dialog
in between tents
for people actually debating,
should we leave? Should we stay
It was about Friday, I think at 11 p.m.
I was having dinner
and our camp and our camp next door was
Chris Rock was there.
Cindy Crawford
Kaia Gerber, Austin Butler.
Michael Key was a bunch of people
were there that were,
you know, living in that camp.
And they had the news
that there was no chance
of leaving tonight
because there's going to be
even more rain forecast.
And the main issue
was getting a car out of
there is really impossible and it's money
because you're going
get stuck in a plane
and a lot of cars stuck on the
on the on the playa.
It's going to create
huge traffic jams
for the eventual exodus of people.
So there was no information
we had to check the 30 minute Twitter.
And I think at 10 a.m.
we said let's regroup
and see if we can walk out of here.
And I was
I said, that's
the only way we can do
it is we can walk out.
And we planned an excursion
the next morning and I think we had out.
Me and about 20 other people
and we just we just walked
and we didn't see many people on the road
and we just, we kept walking.
They said the gate was closed.
It's the general term for the gate.
The gate was on the line cars.
And because people come to Bernie
on the last day for the burn
to love the sun in the Saturday,
but there's no actual gate to
open or closed
it's just the matter of the mud ends
and a paved road begins
and that payroll goes to gridlock.
NAVARRO And we had to walk to about two
that paved road.
Are you still in contact with
people there?
Most of my friends did get out.
I mean, a lot of the deejay friends
I had, Raul asked me how to do it,
and I give them all the bikes.
And I think like ten of my friends
that were back to work this weekend
and this Labor Day weekend, of course,
we have to work.
We all made it out.
A lot of my friends that are
some of them are still there in the camp.
They're having a good time.
They're waiting it out.
You know, this this
the mud always dries up there.
It's the middle of the desert.
You don't expect rain,
but if you have sunshine,
it can dry up in four
or 5 hours with direct stands.
And it has been overcast the whole time.
So it's been really hard to to dry out.
The moment between deciding
you were going to actually
launch the excursion
and the video that I think
everybody in the country
has seen up to this point.
Including the what,
seemingly random appearance of Chris
Rock as you strolled around the camera,
which wasn't so random
since he was in the camp next door.
What what was that like, those hours?
What were you talking
what were you guys doing
as you were kind
of making this trek towards
finally getting picked up?
I think so, yeah.
I mean, for sure,
Chris is going to have a huge bit
in his next
special about Burning Man
because he was really
bizarrely
scared of what what's going to happen.
He thought there was going
to be cannibalism and a day later and,
you know, didn't know
think we're going to run out.
Our camp is still our stuff.
But I said, look, man,
this is a great people
know what they're doing here.
Everybody here is camping.
They all have self-reliance
and we just said I was surprised
he had his New York Knicks check it out.
And we just he just got up that
and started walking
and we walked about 3 hours
in the mud and he was happy.
Was me,
I think Cindy Crawford walked with us,
Kaia Gerber, Austin Butler,
Randy Gerber,
a writer,
a couple of producers
from TV, a couple people
who just want
to get home to their children.
And they didn't take no for an answer.
We're just like, look,
we can make it out.
There's no one stopping us from walking.
And, you know,
it was a challenge,
but it was honestly
one of the highlights of the whole trip
was just getting out there
and enjoying the time out there and,
you know,
seeing the desert
and walking
through the mud and meeting fans
and some kid
recognize me on the road and said,
Hey, I'll give you a ride
the next two miles
and we gladly took it and
we had a good time
in the back of the truck.
We rode for about four miles of the city,
and we sat in a bar for a while
and hung out with people
and finally found a ride arena.
It was like
the old times,
you know, just just this caravan
and across the country,
anything for that kid free tickets or
signed Diplomas merch yeah, I got it.
I got his number.
He lives he lives in about it
is going to come to some shows.
The name was Tony.
He was awesome. Really good guy.
And we found some hippies in the street
that had a sprinter van and we said, hey,
we'll give you $1,000 and we'll Venmo you
if you take us to the airport.
And he had some beer
and we just got in the back of the car.
We just drove for 3 hours
to do something like Neil Young and just
drank some beers. And
somehow I made
the flight and I made the show.
I have no idea
what happened,
but then went to my show in D.C.
It had a great time and now I'm back.
Back in Nevada now
here in Las Vegas for a party.
And yeah, I'm glad I made it up,
but I think I think it's people
that Bernie made.
Organizers are very prepared.
It doesn't rain often
it's the first time,
I think, in history
it rained during the festival,
but it rains sometimes
and they're prepared
for this kind of situation.
I just think the luck of that art
navigating and camping and able to handle
themselves might have been scared, but
it wasn't that bad.
There wasn't any Ebola breakout.
Like like I said,
it means there wasn't any cannibalism.
But it was having a good time.
People
making mud, sculptures,
huge sculptures out of mud
and just kind of continuing
with their art.
And how did you know
there might be other two extra days,
but they had a great time
honestly, between a multi-hour walk
with Chris Rock
and then that car ride you described,
it sounds potentially better than what
I know Burning Man would have been.
Diplo, we really appreciate the time.
Glad you got out.
Awesome. You got to D.C.
and then I guess back
shout out again, Tony.
Yeah, we appreciate it, man.
Thank you.
Bye, guys.
Thanks.
This is what people have been trudging
through for days now.
Festival goers have been hunkering down
and told to conserve their food, water
and fuel.
Emily Bernal is live near the festival.
And Camila,
let's just start with
the latest on the situation
Hey, Audie.
In Philly.
Well, look, it's
still muddy, it's still messy,
and it's still pretty wet
from what we can see in some areas
where exactly
at the main exit
and entrance to the playa.
This is what they call
the eight mile access to the playa.
Right.
And so it's where the playa turns into
the road.
We've seen a couple of cars today
trying to get out of here
even in the middle of the night.
And it's going to be difficult today.
The shelter in place is still on.
The thing is
that if you're trying to get out,
they will let you,
but you're going to have
a very difficult time.
I want to show you
what the vehicles
of the Bureau of Land and Management
look like.
They've been in that mud
and they are completely covered in mud.
The operation here
is just getting started
because they're waiting for thousands
and thousands to try to get out
but the people that get out their cars
look like this.
And the people
that are trying to walk out
have told me, look,
it's taken me 3 hours.
What they end up doing
is that they get these plastic bags
and wrap their shoes with duct tape.
And they've told me
that really is the only way
that you can walk for miles and miles
as you try to get out
to make it to this road to the main exit.
Again, it's just difficult.
People were not expecting
so much rain, so much mud,
but a lot of people
that I've talked to have remained
extremely positive.
Look,
they say
they've had a great time at the festival.
They say
that they have enjoyed their time here.
And they're trying to make the best
out of a very difficult situation.
But officials are telling them
conserve food,
conserve water, fuel,
because if they do have to stay here
for extra days,
a lot of them
do not have enough food or water
for just a number of days
that they had no plan for it.
That's really the concern
for a lot of people.
They have been sharing
This is an event
where people
essentially feel free to self express,
to create art, to come together.
So you're seeing those vibes,
you're seeing that positivity.
But officials here are saying
just be careful
because you still
may not be able to get out today.
They're saying
they're going to look again
when the sun comes out, decide
after they look at the mud
and the conditions
and how things improve or not.
So in the meantime,
we're just waiting for the sun
to come up to see how things are going to
end up going for today.
But so far, it's still looking muddy
and it's still looking messy.
So we do expect to see people coming out.
The question is whether officials
will give them that green light
and make it official.
Guys. Yeah, wait and see.
Hopefully lives
can be like we're reporting.
Thanks so much.